space is an incredibly dangerous place
if you do something wrong it's game over
so the stakes are very high to keep
everyone safe we practice routinely
emergency procedures I think the biggest
emergency is is loss of depress or
depressurization if something's coming
at you and hits the space station and
that's going to cause a breach and it
could be something as small as two
centimeters in diameter that could do a
lot of damage everyone would go to their
respective vehicle and close the hatches
because initially if it's very fast you
only have so much time to get in that
vehicle safe it and be ready to go home
another situation we trained for is fire
if a fire alarm goes off on our computer
screen you would see the actual module
where the smoke detectors think you're
seeing a fire and then you would
actually physically go there to see if
that you actually have identify smoke or
flames or anything coming out and the
solar flare the Sun kind of burps every
so often and sends out high-energy
particles from the sun's the dangers
around solar flares or that you can
accumulate too much radiation in your
body if there's a solar flare all of the
astronauts flow up into the doghouse we
call it that has a ton of water bags
surrounding it and the water will absorb
and keep the radiation from coming into
our bodies and we just wait until
Houston gives us the call to say
everything's clear
as astronauts you're trained to not be
alarmed by things you're trained to go
into a mode of how will I save the day
how will I fix this how will I do all
the steps required to make sure that you
know we come home safely